Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Try that again.
HAJIMARU YO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
That was strange.
It's okay, Moco-chan.
Because I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, like every other FUWAMOCO almost, we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us for our 117th episode!
Our first episode after our 3D debut!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Are you surprised, Ruffians?
Maybe we're looking a little bit like usual.
Moco-chan, you have to call the doctor a little bit first, alright?
Yeah, my eyes are feeling a little bit funny, huh?
So we'll be like this for now?
Yeah!
Okay!
Well, let's continue our morning here!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Wow, for any Ruffians joining us for the first time today!
You know, after our 3D and everything, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's throw BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Another brand new weekend!
A very, very special weekend!
Let's start it on the right paw, okay?
We don't need to worry about things because
Well... I think... There might have been a Pero Sighting.
Ruffians!
Let's take a look, Moco-chan.
Okay.
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Why?
Why does Pero have to crash our 3D debut, huh?
We didn't see him for so long and then now!
Of all times!
You know, I thought maybe... He was just busy with his birthday party and... You know, he'd be up to whatever he gets up to, but... No!
He has to go and crash our 3D debut, huh?
Well, Ruffians!
Hopefully we showed him!
You know, do you think, do you think he realizes that WE'RE THE TALK DOG!
Yeah!
Don't want Pero, yeah!
Nobody wants Pero!
Why?
Should we have been harder on him, you know?
Maybe some more punches would have been better, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
He celebrated your 300th debut!
You wanted to congratula- That was not a congratulation!
He said he was the star of the show!
Yeah!
More kicks.
More kicks?
Can I stomp him?
I could do more kicks.
STOMP!
Ah, that's chill.
We punched.
Yeah.
Just jump all over him.
And we're... Ah, next time into space.
That did pretty well.
He went into the atmosphere.
Yeah.
The atmosphere is different from space, Moco-chan.
But it's pretty close!
I don't know.
Maybe we could've, we could've done it a little bit better.
Do some wrestling moves on him!
It's very round though.
Yeah, he doesn't have any limbs, you know.
I guess we could grab a wing, but... We could just pull off the wings.
We could!
The wings... Maybe the eyes, the eyes, you know.
Eyes are a weak point.
How's that?
Yeah.
But that would be kinda nasty, sticking your fingers into Pero's eyes.
It would probably feel like blueberries.
Nasty eyes.
Hot.
Pero's blueberries?
Uh-uh.
Well, we showed him who's boss, right?
Yeah, we're the top dogs!
Right?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Should be gone for a while now.
For a while, yeah.
Yeah, he's scared.
BAU BAU!
Well, I think it's kinda obvious what this is.
FUWAMOCO!
We made our 3D debut!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
You saw right!
Right!
We had a ton of fun!
Yeah!
You watched right!
You were damn right!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
But, oh my gosh.
We're so exhausted now.
Yeah.
You do!
We song and we dance!
Yeah!
We beat a Pero!
We wrestle!
Yeah!
You know?
I did a lot.
I think we probably made some Ruffians cry too!
I think it was pretty busy, huh?
Yeah, but you know... We're really happy because... Yeah!
I think we were able to show off everything that we practiced so hard.
You're only there for the archive?
That's fine!
Oh, thank you!
Not only!
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll let you cry.
That's okay!
You know, it makes us really happy whether you're able to be there live or you know, maybe things are a little bit busy, you have work, maybe you're sleeping.
But we were so nervous!
We were really nervous, but I'm glad we were able to do everything the best we could.
I thought you enjoyed it with us.
Yeah, and Ruffians!
Thank you so much for being there, for watching the archive over and over, and for tweeting with our hashtag!
Hashtag FWMC3D so much too!
You know, it was actually trending worldwide for so long despite, you know, there is Kumike and Olympic squadron!
Hi!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Apparently it's not a mistake, apparently it is true.
I don't know.
It feels kind of funny.
FUWAMOCO World Domination!
Yay!
BAU BAU!
You've watched it for the third time already?
Thank you!
Yeah, well, third time makes us really happy, but we hope that you know you'll watch it over and over, especially your favorite parts, and maybe you can share those with your friends too, Ruffians!
Yeah!
But, you know, we put our... Every fiber of our flippin' fiber to our 3D debut!
It's all of us!
But, you know, we hope that we can continue to do even more amazing things with our 3D bodies here in hololive!
So please look forward to it and cheer us on, okay, Ruffians?
You love Somi Shinne Taigyou?
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh my!
They wouldn't understand!
Your friends wouldn't understand!
Well, you don't know until you try.
Just tell them, okay?
See, there's these two twin demon dogs.
And one of them you might think is a chihuahua.
She's not a chihuahua, her name is Fuwawa.
And then you know, because they're twins, you might think the other one, oh that's Fuwawa.
No, that's not Fuwawa, that's Mococo.
Yeah, it's easy, okay?
Yeah, and then you just say, you know,
They go bau bau, they sing, they dance, they wrestle!
Yeah, sing, dance, wrestle, huh?
Yeah, and they'll protect you as well, and then... Yeah!
Easy dance!
They understand, right?
Just like that.
Right?
There's nothing hard to understand.
Not... not chihuahua.
Not chihuahua?
No.
Not Fuwawa.
Then who is Kororo and Okaka?
Oh, well you have to watch a 3D showcase to find out then, huh?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
There was a lot of surprising things that happened in our 3D debut.
But our first song!
Did you see the end?
Oh, the end?
Yeah.
Our end card.
You know what, right?
All I'm feeling...
I'm a gem for you too.
But the very first song we sung, well, it was our original introduction song, Lifetime Showtime!
Yeah, but a little bit different from our usual.
The first time, we sung the full version of Lifetime Showtime!
We surprised Ruffians!
Yeah, the full version.
Yeah, all of a sudden it continues!
Yeah, you know, finally we're able to share the full version with you!
We're just so happy to be able to unveil it during our 3D debut!
Especially because it's a song that's grown together with us over the past year, ever since we debuted.
And, well, it's written by Suopatora Onesa!
She's a very, very popular Vtuber!
She's amazing!
So talented at everything!
Yeah!
And she puts so many special things into, you know, Moco-chan!
Today!
You know, you sneeze so much, and just all our feelings are so, so far!
And so much more!
That's exactly what we wanted, you know!
When we both have a favorite part, a favorite lyric from, you know, it's a... Bring your smile, bring your shine.
We'll protect you, won't forget our pledge to you.
That point, you know, because every time we sing it, you know, we really, really mean it, Ruffians.
From the bottom of our hearts.
You know, Lifetime Showtime, it's a song that's really, really special to us.
So we want to make sure that when we can finally properly release it to you, that it's done properly and very special.
So please wait a little longer, okay?
Just a little longer, hopefully.
However long is necessary.
Please look forward to the release.
When it happens.
When it happens, speedy TBA.
We're looking forward to it.
So... BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
You've waited a year!
You can't wait forever!
I know!
I feel like that too!
Why?
Wait longer, please.
Moco-chan said please, so... Yeah, I said please, okay?
I said please, that's the magic word, so now you have to.
Yeah, you have to.
She said please.
Got it!
Furitsuke no Kawaii Kata!
Thank you!
The choreography was done by Sakakibara Yuu-sensei!
Yuu-sensei!
Yeah!
And she's a really famous singer, seiyuu!
And she also does dance and choreography too!
But you might know her from like the
Steins Gate ending theme.
Yeah.
Chaos Cat.
There's lots and lots of them.
She has so many different roles and we really admire her so we're gonna shout it out!
Definitely have a lot of performances.
Definitely don't have a signature.
Definitely, definitely.
Yeah, so we're really happy.
Please take another listen, maybe watch over a performance on Lifetime Showtime.
Okay, Ruffians?
Bye bye!
Not just singing and dancing, no.
And not just beating a Pero.
We also mentioned that we did pro wrestling!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I won!
Yes!
Moco-chan, you had to pick this moment!
Yes.
Hi!
Victory pose!
Yeah!
Yeah, but I think we probably surprised you the most with the pro wrestling, right, Ruffians?
Yeah?
Yeah.
You know, we had a 3D after party.
We talked a bunch about everything, especially at pro wrestling.
In detail.
Yeah, so if you're really curious, please go check that out.
But we are both really happy to be able to fight it out over that one donut!
Yeah, and it's all thanks to DDT Pro Wrestling's help.
Yeah.
And they're guidance that we're able to do it.
You know, I think a lot of Ruffians are saying like, oh, I can see Fuwamoco.
They've done this a lot.
They're professionals.
No.
Not at all!
We're complete beginners of K!
Yeah!
I know!
Even like, from, even just wrestling together, but even just when it comes to pro wrestling, yeah!
We're beginners!
Yeah, we really admire pro wrestlers.
Yeah!
We think they're really cool, just like idols too!
Yeah, I feel like- They're just a little bit bigger, and more like BAU BAU, rather than BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Believe in someone who really respected them beforehand, but of course we have a newfound respect too!
Yeah!
We trained really, really hard to be able to do it!
And our sensei was super, super, super kind!
But it was a really, really hard schedule, you know, to be able to do everything.
You know, we had our streams, recordings, meetings and homework, dance practice, wrestling practice, team practice.
Yeah, some days it would be like,
Stream.
Meeting.
Homework.
Wrestling.
Dancing.
Recording.
Yeah.
Some days it'll just be all of them all together, right?
It was a lot!
Just a bit busy!
Yeah, but we're glad we're busy!
We really like seeing us at each other's throats!
Yeah!
And you know the great Okan!
A really famous Japanese wrestler that he was hololive at!
Was watching and cheering us on on Twitter.
We're so happy!
Yeah!
The Great Okazaki even won a big match today as well!
CRU Shoumedetou!
Did you like it, Ruffians?
Would you like to see hololive Wrestling with our senpai someday?
hololive Wrestling!
Yes!
Yeah!
Well, if you want that to happen, you're gonna need to be extra loud because... The staff.
The 3D team.
They almost died trying to make this happen, you know?
Yeah.
But nothing's impossible, right?
Right, Ruffians?
So you're gonna need to be extra loud if you want to do more wrestling.
Yeah!
Extra, extra loud.
Yeah.
For a 3D team.
Yeah, they're experienced now.
Yes.
But... Does that make things better?
hololive Summer!
Ah!
hololive Summer Wrestling!
Resting in bathing water.
Is that what you want?
Oh my gosh!
Lunch is what you want.
Wow.
And then afterwards, I'm a chihuahua!
I'm disappointed in you, Ruffians!
You're gonna need to be extra loud, okay, Ruffians!
Hi!
Yeah, summer beach wrestling, right?
I saw with mud.
With mud?
Idols.
We're idols, Ruffians!
There's nothing to do with idols and mud.
No.
Don't misunderstand, okay?
BAU BAU!
Speaking of misunderstandings... Obvious.
This has been a pretty big misunderstanding, okay?
It's been such a while since we had a misunderstanding, but this is a big misunderstanding!
That was a lot of desk slams, right?
Yeah.
Obvious.
You know, I'm sure there were a lot of things in our 3D debut that made you overload, you know?
FUWAMOCO.
They're fluffy and fuzzy.
But... But... You know!
What you were seeing.
Especially during the wrestling!
Yeah.
It wasn't underwear.
OK!
Yeah.
White shima-shima shorts!
Shima-shima shorts, yeah.
Just, you know, blue and white, and pink and white striped shorts.
Yeah.
No pants!
So it's nothing to be embarrassed about, right?
Yeah.
But it's...
It's embarrassing when the Ruffians make silly faces like that though.
Why?
Yeah.
It shouldn't be embarrassing.
Don't look too much, okay?
Ruffians!
We're not those kind of demon dogs, okay?
We don't show our underwear, okay?
There's Shima Shima shorts!
Shima Shima shorts, okay.
Got it.
Just ignore the fact that Moco-chan's wearing shorts under her shorts.
Yeah.
Yeah!
It's just normal, okay?
So it's another story.
This normal makes sense, yeah.
No misunderstanding!
Understood!
Say it!
Say understood, Ruffians!
Say it, Ruffians!
You understand.
Shima-shima shorts.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Understood.
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Good.
No misunderstanding.
Understood.
Shima-shima shorts.
Bye-bye!
Yeah.
Awkward.
Well, Ruffians, you know our 3D debut is now done, but we still have our album 3D collab.
Yeah, don't forget about that, okay?
Also, Breaking Dimension Hall in Ippushu's second concert is gonna be happening very shortly.
And look at this new key video!
Look over!
It came out right before our 3D debut on the official hololive Universe channel.
I'm ready to break those dimensions!
Now what is Breaking Dimensions?
Breaking Dimensions is a brand new concert.
It's gonna be happening in New York City at the King's Theatre.
Second whole life English concert ever!
Not just one day, it's two days!
Happening on August 24th and August 25th.
Thanks to...
Everyone's excitement too!
All the tickets are sold out!
But there are streaming tickets!
Streaming tickets!
Get your streaming tickets!
That means you don't need to go to New York!
You don't need to leave your home to be able to go and join in on the excitement!
You can get the streaming tickets online from SPWM or e-plus!
So please make sure you get your streaming tickets!
Oh they also announced some new merchandise!
There's a bunch of other things but
The Krillic Stands.
I'm most excited about the Krillic Stands!
Look, look, Ruffians!
You can put them together in any combination you like!
So like, if you're like, okay, well these are my oshi, I need all my oshi all together.
Look, look, look, look!
Oh, it says!
Right!
Right, so you can put, you know, like, okay.
I'm just excited you can have mid-Romance Advent!
Wait, all together?
I was excited about that too, but then it's like... I sort of need it.
You can put all your oshi together.
I sort of need it.
What?
But why?
Yes!
Yeah, and look what they're all together!
I just thought, why would you split everyone apart?
But I guess you could, huh?
You could.
You could be a little bit, well... This is just for my own enjoyment.
Nobody will know.
I need them all!
Right.
Right?
Such a good idea, right?
Yeah!
And it's all so cute!
So please make sure you check out those.
There's also other merch available as well!
Yeah!
The sales period is from August 10th to September 17th.
So please check that out!
Oh, okay!
It's sort of limited.
Yeah.
But Ruffians, also please make sure that you're ready with your preface!
Because it's gonna be a concert.
Never ever forget.
Advent's first concert too!
And together it's always so fun!
Yeah, please meet up with other Ruffians too!
Have fun together!
And you know, if you're not going to New York, that doesn't mean that you can't meet up with other Ruffians.
Right, right.
Maybe there's other Ruffians that are close to where you are!
Well, I do.
The power of the internet.
The internet.
Right.
Please look forward to more fun details of coming to Kimo Friends!
BAU BAU!
You know, we released our schedule earlier this week.
But we had something that was a bit mysterious on it, huh?
Yeah, we're doing a lot of karaoke this week.
But one of those, the most mysterious one,
The mystery has been solved!
We're gonna be doing a karaoke collab together with AZKi-senpai and Akura-senpai!
BAU BAU!
We're so so happy!
We're so excited!
It's gonna be our first time singing with both AZKi-senpai and Akura-senpai!
And we're so happy because AZKi-senpai invited us!
And we really wanted to be able to, you know we haven't been able to chat or interact with Aqua-senpai that much, so we are really happy to be able to be a part of this!
Yeah!
We figured, you know, she's gonna be very busy and there are lots of other senpai that want to spend time with her, so...
We're so happy to be included in this!
So a big thank you to ASCUE-senpai!
But we're gonna have a bunch of fun!
It's gonna be really silly, really cute, and we're also gonna sing a lot of nostalgic songs, anime songs!
It's going to be really fun, so please join us!
I know FUWAMOCO, we made a little bit of a mistake on our schedule.
Instead of being a, I think,
5 a.m.
PT.
It's one hour later.
It's one later at 6 a.m.
PT.
And it's on AZKi-senpai's channel, okay?
So please join us.
It's a little bit early, maybe for some Ruffians.
But it's gonna be like that, okay?
Yeah.
Have lots of fun, okay?
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy!
One hour later, we made a little bit of a mistake.
It's gonna be another exciting week with a bunch of different things going on.
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Happy the Yorkies!
Wow, that's so tiny!
So baby!
Yeah!
With those little wings!
Riot, as a demon dog, likes white and blue.
I approve!
That's why they're so happy!
Look at it!
So small!
They're very cute!
Hugging them.
IRyS-senpai dakimakura chu!
It's sort of funny.
Good taste!
More funny!
It's sort of funny.
Okay.
Hugging IRyS-senpai.
Oh no!
Mocho!
Mocho happy!
IRyS-senpai's gonna take you for a osampo!
What?
Yeah.
How does... How does... Happy BAU BAU?
Not IRyS-senpai.
How does IRyS-senpai BAU BAU?
How does... Happy BAU BAU?
Maybe like...
BAU BAU!
BAU!
BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU-BAU
Ruffians.
There's a lot of exciting things, but of course you went out for a walk, right?
Yeah, right!
Let's see where you went for a walk.
Today's I went on a walk is... Da-den!
Oh, thank you for getting Icomochi-mama's books at Comiket!
It sounds like it was a really amazing at Comiket.
We're doing our 3D debut!
Yeah!
You know, we were really busy with our debut!
But we were still super readable everyone there.
It was very very hot!
Very dangerous!
Crazy hot!
Yeah, but we're glad that you're safe and that you got your treasures too!
Thank you so much to all the Ruffians who went to Icomochi-mama's books, and you know, especially also to all the Ruffians who released the books, and we read so much too!
We read there was a lot of circles in FUWAMOCO books this year!
Yeah!
We're really happy!
You know, because one of our big goals is to get FUWAMOCO doujinshi, get a person down.
So we're really happy that you're making lots and lots of works of art.
And we hope you know that maybe there are even more doing next week's weekend!
BAU BAU!
We're excited!
I'm just imagining Winter Comiket now.
I'm excited.
Summer Comiket is hot.
But Winter Comiket is cold.
Yeah.
Did we get a question on the day, Moco-chan?
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Watching Futajiri.
That's a new anime.
Futajiri.
Love is not inter... visible?
By twins.
Yeah.
Made me curious about your teenage years.
You told us that you always got along and your fights were always quickly resolved.
But did you go through any rebellious phases related to being twins?
Like questioning your role as older or younger sister?
Inoue!
We're 2000 plus years old now.
Bye.
It's been a while since then, hi.
But... No.
No.
No rebellious faces ever.
Yeah.
Mama puppy!
No, she always says that we're very well-behaved.
Yeah.
I guess in tour.
Demon guide dog training and then we kinda got a bit distracted and did some mischief and... You know what?
It's fine.
It was good.
We didn't do anything wrong.
Yeah.
You know, just having some fun.
Yeah!
It's good.
But, yeah, you know, I'm the older sister.
You know, and I'm the younger sister.
Yeah, but we're still twins.
No fights.
No questioning.
Just all around good and the same.
Yup.
No phases.
No.
Nothing that interesting.
Yeah.
What?
Are you disappointed, Ruffy?
Aw.
Yeah.
Shiori no fights!
Well, you know, we kinda had a bit of a squabble over the donut.
Yeah, I think.
Because we were both sitting on the sofa.
We had a big squabble about the placement on the sofa.
Whether it should be an inch over this way or an inch over that way.
In the end it doesn't matter because the sofa kinda moves around a little bit.
Yeah.
It doesn't really matter in the end.
No.
Yeah.
Ugh.
No wrestling!
Not on a normal basis!
No!
Yeah.
Solve it with wrestling again!
Well, unless we have a very good reason.
Yeah.
Donuts are a good reason.
Exactly.
The last pondering is a good reason.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Please let us know.
I'm sure you have more questions, right?
Especially with our 3D debut and everything.
So please ask us.
You can use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Also your walks.
There's been some very beautiful walks that the Ruffians have been going on.
Please show us where you're going, okay?
And with your peril sightings.
I'm sure that
Pero's probably gonna be going around to a bunch of different places.
So please let us know, Ruffians, what kind of places you see him in.
We have no clue where he went, hon.
Yeah, also Doggie of the Day.
I'm sure there's a lot of doggies out there playing, having a lot of fun, summer fun.
Yes, I would like to be the Doggie of the Day, hon!
Please let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
Our next stream.
We have the
For our doggy pack, we're gonna be watching The Princess Bride.
It's our first time watching it.
I have no clue what it's about.
The princesses become brides.
The movie's over.
You wanted to watch it, Doggy Pack, so... Go watch it!
Yeah!
It's a little bit earlier than usual!
So please make sure that you don't... Oh!
I made a mistake!
Now it's over!
Two hours late!
So...
Please join us, okay?
It's gonna be at 4 p.m.
PT.
BAU BAU!
Our schedule, you know!
Yes!
So we have our karaoke with AZKi-senpai and Aqua-senpai at 5 a.m.
PT.
I made a mistake.
5 a.m.
PT.
It's one hour later than what we have on the schedule because we made a mistake.
We made a mistake.
So it's really just three hours earlier than FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah.
Just a bit of an earlier morning, right?
An earlier morning.
And then we have Sakura with Five again!
And Wednesday with FUWAMOCO Morning.
Followed by an off-club karaoke with Biboo!
Yeah!
We're gonna have fun!
Diamond dogs and Saimei dogs.
We're really excited!
Excited!
And Thursday's gonna be a bit of a homework day for us.
Wish us luck.
But Friday, we have a main cafe, Totsumachi Main Cafe call.
It's what we're gonna be doing very early at 6AM PT.
And this part of the whole summer bingo.
I wonder which senpai will call us.
Otherwise, you know, maybe we'll just have to serve the Ruffians.
Oh, we were like that all, huh?
Yeah, and then we have another FUWAMOCO Morning!
And after that, we have a FUWAMOCO Rock n' Roll Party!
Somehow they always end up to be on the Fridays recently.
But this time, our theme is hololive ONLY songs!
In our Breaking Dimensions, we made our 3D debut.
It's time that we sing some hololive songs.
It's been a while.
So we hope you'll join us.
We're gonna sing a bunch of our senpai songs.
Or maybe some other new ones as well.
BAU BAU!
And then, it's the Abbott 3D debut collab!
Happening on Saturdays at Misabot- Misabot?
Miss it!
Saturday at 8pm PT!
I feel like a lot of Ruffians are forgetting about it.
Why?
There's been so many exciting things that maybe you might be like, oh, that's it.
No!
It's not over!
It's continuing!
Yeah, all five of us, all of Abbott will be together!
And it's gonna be silly.
Yeah.
Cause it's pretty silly when we're all together.
And then after that, it's a very busy day for us.
We're off to sell popcorn!
And we're gonna be doing a Rock n' Rawr Party mini.
Followed by a meet and greet!
So if you're a Ruffian, you're in for it!
See you there!
And then on Sunday early morning at 3AM CTM, we're gonna be doing an off-clock with Hachima-senpai!
Playing a very scary game, Horoku-kun.
We played it, it was very scary.
We're gonna start from the beginning again, cause we didn't get very far, huh?
Yeah, and it's gonna be Hachima-senpai's first time playing it, and I'm pretty sure she'll help us a lot right now.
Yeah, right?
That's the whole point, right?
Well, as high as I'm a senpai, you never know.
And then at 6 p.m.
PT, we're gonna be playing Aqua-senpai's visual novel, Aquarium!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we love visual novels.
It's our dream to have our own visual novel.
So we're gonna play Aqua-senpai's visual novel.
And maybe we can take some notes, learn a few things.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
This week, coming right on up.
And for all of you who are joining us today through the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO word.
It's BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for the first FUWAMOCO Morning after our 3D debut!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
John Apple!
BAU BAU!
Chuu Udon!
Make out islands.
BAU BAU!
Iful.
Ka-fune.
BAU BAU!
Poodle.
Cowboy.
BAU BAU!
Soekuroi.
Rikachino.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!